hey everybody and welcome to a brand new
project this is called Stella var and
it'll be a collaboration between me as
well as Oprah you know and also Rudy hey
there so yeah from this point onward
we're just gonna try and do a bit of a
joint recording here although I also
have to say the quality might not be the
best we're recording this kind of late
at night and also I'm going through a
cold at the moment which is why we
haven't been able to do this earlier but
yeah we're here now and that's all that
matters I think it is yep yep so I think
you guys can explain a little bit more
about how this projects kind of came to
be right because I only enjoyed this at
a later stage well yeah it kind of was
created in a comment section of another
video I don't really want to go too deep
into it but it was more or less like
lush idea I guess at the very beginning
but it appeared that a few minutes later
like the disco chat was created and then
a few people joined the chat and we were
creating the idea of yeah having an
awesome coaster and and really theme it
to the maximum possible in planet
coaster at at the moment and yeah for
several reasons which you don't really
need to name here it didn't really work
out the way it was initially planned but
yeah some of us I didn't really want to
go let go and wanted to keep it on and
so we asked self if we kind of wants to
jump in besides with other projects
which sometimes just appear and then
never reappeared so but know we all know
that self likes to build coasters and so
we thought okay it might make sense to
bring him and might give a good
connection and that's yeah how it all
was created and I feel like it was just
more or less like a lush idea that yeah
turned out to be some cool looking
product now yeah we hope of course all
right
well yeah I hope you guys are happy with
the layout so far I was actually really
interested in the general theme of this
ride especially because
last week I went to Estonia for a school
excursion and a surprisingly large part
of the program was visiting old
abandoned buildings from you know the
USSR period and just before that as well
and one of the things we did is we went
to the city called Narva in the Far East
of Estonia bordering on Russia and this
is pretty much the only Russian city in
the European Union like 99% of the
people in the town spoke Russian there
were barely any Estonians at all and it
was a very post-industrial town and they
have this huge abandoned factory called
claim home and I think which we visited
and it was absolutely amazing actually
got a lot of inspiration from that as
well and I just really dig that whole
aesthetic and we've also been looking
for a lot of reference pictures of what
this whole project would look like so
yeah I'm really I'm here for it yeah and
I have to say a huge props also to to a
proto who came up actually with the
theme when we're talking about the theme
at the very beginning and in the chat we
were still brainstorming a bit about
what it will look like and how we could
theme that coaster I may have to say
that there was another type of coastal
plant at the beginning which way of them
also you know needed a little bit of a
different theming to be honest but we
somehow came up with that topic as I
said operator came up with it and I
think we - we actually loved it from the
first second and so yeah I think this is
why it turned out and yeah it's a happy
coincidence I guess so that you were
able to visit them and get your
inspiration from there because clearly I
couldn't so yeah I feel like this is a
really cool thing that you were really
able to to get some more real-life
things out of it and I have to say I
really dig this this theme quite a bit
I've never touched it to be honest so
yeah we're looking forward to it that's
also Chris Lewis that self at you went
there and we actually came up with Timmy
and name for it also be just before you
went to the trip so yeah yep yeah no
it's definitely all coincidental I
didn't even know that
we were going to do that sort of thing
on the excursion so that was actually
really cool and also I have to say
credit goes to operator for the
structures that you see at the beginning
of the park as well which I think will
upload as a sort of episode zero because
they're kind of like preparation for the
rest of the project but the coaster
isn't there yet yeah it was kind of a
prototype to set the theming and maybe
just to get the idea on how it would
look
yeah which is awesome because I have to
say that you know with operator and I
guess most of you people out there will
know him from from his awesome
recreations and also or some other
project I have to say what I love about
your work always is like how freakin
precise that is and this is this is like
really I when you sent over the first
pictures I was like yes it's exactly
this you know with the crane and stuff I
don't want to spoil too much because
still people should watch that one but
yeah that's for mixer yeah I only can
say that this really goes into a
direction that looks totally fancy and
somewhat unseen it's not that used to
you know it's not that theme that you're
used to seeing quite often in in theme
parks or whatnot so yeah I'm really
happy to see and also to go on with that
and to work on what you've already
started to work with at the beginning so
yeah it's kind of a cool first initial
prototype a proof of concept of you yeah
thanks yeah it was something I already
wanted to build a very long time he
plant goes to but I have a lot of
projects now and I really didn't want to
start something new but of course with
you guys it's just something yeah
kick-started it of course you get in
touch with over me and don't worry there
will be always a new project yeah for
sure but I really don't mind well start
a new project but I just don't want to
start again something that takes too
long but I think yeah me first the
initial idea was to keep this small but
yeah yeah I think we still consider to
keep it as small as possible I
call it here I don't want to do awfully
crazy promises because we all know that
we barely ever keep up to them but I
think this will be more like having one
as far as I understood as far as I think
like like kind of heavy theming around
the station and then kind of uses also a
bit more like landscaping and you know
and environmental elements rather than
just making it all very heavily theme
but yeah we never know how it will come
up in the end the coaster is rather
compact anyway so we the plan was well
my plan was to have like a small like
workers village somewhere in there and
then work around like you said scenery
and landscaping like a parking lot and
all desert its of course yeah and
everything should should like being very
broken and rusty and like yeah I like
this yeah well I really like that idea
actually that was one of the things that
we also noted on our visit to the
factory in Nova is that they have these
workers villages right next to the
factory as well where she I didn't even
know that but you know yeah it's kind of
makes sense if you talk about that yeah
I really have to say I like how the
coaster is turning out I mean I've seen
some screens in advance but I've never
seen how Yuri were working on it
so smoothing like hell but it's turning
all really great yeah I guess I should
probably save it about this because I
haven't said too much about the actual
coaster then I'm building here so the
main inspiration was takabisha in fuji-q
highland what with that launch and large
vertical lift hill and the drop and
that's just the general sort of way that
the layout goes as well as it's really
large elements many of which are
inversions and you know taking them
quite slowly so you get a lot of hang
time at the top of each inversion and
all together on a very small footprint
so it has this this really cool even
industrial kind of look to the layout
itself I think
and I think it works quite well for a
project like this absolutely yeah
I also I like the lift Hill itself like
the the base structure of the lift Hill
and I mean this is even the more
recently added one isn't it that so it
can have really looks awesome in itself
already like really detailed with all
the pipe work and stuff
so I think this is really nicely yeah we
can easily easily integrate that in the
overall theming sand it's kind of cool
yep
yeah that's actually something worth
noting as well teka beitia is a
Eurofighter and this coaster is an
infinity coaster by the same
manufacturer and there are some things
that I have to be honest I wasn't too
happy about with this infinity coaster
mostly the fact that the articulation of
the trains isn't realistic but also you
know the fact that we got this coaster
type in the game is absolutely awesome
this is one of my favourite coaster
types and a huge fan favorite for
coaster enthusiasts that people have
been hoping for for a really long time
and I think the execution with those
lift hills and just how flexible this
thing is because this thing is instantly
become the coaster type with the most
that with the largest amount of special
track pieces in the game I think it's
really flexible and it's really fun to
build layouts with and it's not too
difficult to make it smooth either for
most of these inversions I ended up
using the trick of building it first and
trying to get it as smooth as possible
and then deleting all the pieces and
letting the the autocomplete feature
finish the pieces so you get these
really smooth rolls and with a lot of
trial and error you can actually get
very smooth inversions with this I found
it super cool so that I mean to you
didn't really use the 4 meter method
throughout the whole layout in you know
barely actually just the the first
barrel roll at the start of the layout
is 4 meter method 4 meter method but
even that one eye for metered the heck
out of it but then I removed the 4 meter
pieces and let it let the the
autocomplete feature pretty much do the
roll and it's
to be a really smooth barrel roll it's
not perfect but I think for you know a
player made barrel roll
it looks quite good okay you know from I
can tell from from your sense of not
perfect it is definitely really
sufficient for us yeah like I have to
add two things so first of all you love
the coaster manufacturer however I just
checked it's not your most favorite ones
at least in your newest category you put
out on Twitter it's only in the second
category so do you want to talk about
that yeah that's that's i never expected
you'd bring that up but yeah so there's
this youtube channel called canada
coaster fan who made a tier list of
coaster manufacturers and i was waiting
for this for a long time I was actually
checking out the tea lists website this
is a website where anybody can create a
tier list and they can fill it in with
whatever you want and I was waiting for
anybody to make a coaster manufacturer T
list and all of a sudden a short while
ago he made one and I created my own
division my own ranking if you will of
coaster manufacturers in that and put it
on Twitter and it caused for many people
a lot of agreements but also for many
people a lot of controversy and
disagreement with me over how I divided
my coaster manufacturers but I remember
I put RMC intamin and great coasters
international on the top tier and then a
bunch of coaster manufacturers in the
tier just below that including girl hour
if I remember that's true apparently I
just needed to laugh on so hard as I was
seeing it in your last year there was
some panner in and initially I thought
wait a second isn't that a Toyota model
and I was like wait a second no that's
what I made have off of the the freakin
video repeat for the first of April like
the Primo hard one I called it the
Toyota summer why did I and I was like
oh yeah because that shitty manufacturer
that's why and so I needed to nuts when
I saw that that's the one with Ferrari
Costa writes yep yep so yeah you have
written all the manufacturers that you
listed or how does it work no actually
no I excluded gravity group out of the
list because I thought I hadn't written
a gravity group coaster apparently I
have I just forgot about it I've written
one adrenaline which I thought was
absolutely brilliant but yeah I
generally excluded the companies that I
haven't ridden coasters of or just can't
give a good judgement of but Zamperla is
so bad that I felt I could just put it
down there and nobody would disagree
with me oh yeah I can only agree from by
by watching videos I think I never have
I don't think so they've made a lot of
flats rights so you've probably been on
some of their rides
maybe just out there coasters might be
yeah because like I have to say I still
have to fill in a lot of gaps in terms
of kosis I mean I've been riding quite a
lot of coasters in terms of overall
amount but unfortunately not that
variety out of it because like mainly
sticking to Europe so yeah because
whenever us to be able to ride coaster
I was just way too young and actually
too small if you will I wasn't too young
eventually but I was too small which is
really a pity I remember being in this
narrow distant land Florida and also
SeaWorld Florida we are also quite a few
of coasters I could have written them
all in terms of age but I was always too
small for it because I yeah even at the
age of 8 I was way too small
so yeah bit unfortunate but hey that's
it how it is so I have to go there
eventually someday again yeah I also
found it interesting how people from
different continents really rated
different manufacturers differently so I
I should say though that were different
a little bit less there but you know a
lot of Europeans seem to rate the coma
quite highly we've got some good for
comas in Europe I think that's only but
then my character Joe is influencing
them all maybe that too but I think
everybody who's been in Poland and wrote
those polish for comas is rating them
way up on their list those things are
amazing but then all the Americans put
it all the way down in there
because America doesn't get any good for
comments and I think the same kind of
goes for Togo I put Togo in a decently
high tier and this is a manufacturer
which everybody hates you know it never
seems to get any good ratings because
America and while Europe barely got any
Togo Zephir
I think but America's got a lot of
really bad Togo coasters but I've only
written Togo coasters in Japan and I
thought that with it they were quite
good so it's interesting how you get
completely different experiences in
different continents sometimes that's
true yeah anyway we're currently at the
end of the video pretty much so I think
that'll be it for today I'll just let
the final POV and cinematics speak for
themselves with some music and yeah I'd
like to thank really an operator for
being here today with this commentary
and for allowing me to be part of this
series yeah no problem
you're welcome Thanks and of course if
you like to follow the rest of the
series please subscribe to their
channels as well there will be lots of
interesting content maybe I'll come back
to do a supports video or something like
that we'll see how we can divide the
tasks eventually and yeah I'm looking
forward to how this project will pan out
yep me too
same here mm-hmm okay all right bye bye
bye bye guys
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay hold up this video isn't quite over
yet I wanted to go over the layouts and
the different elements that I put into
this because normally that's something
that I would talk about doing the
time-lapse but with our whole joint
commentary and trying to explain how
those projects actually came to be I
couldn't talk too much about the layout
itself and especially in light of my
recent planet coaster college video on
this same coaster I think it'd be
interesting to go over some of the
elements and maybe give some tips and
ideas along the way and just show my
thought process into how this layouts
came to be so starting off here we have
the barrel roll right off to the station
I'm actually quite proud of this one
it's very smooth this is probably the
smoothest barrel roll I've ever been
able to make in the game especially one
that actually is hard lined it's
definitely not perfect as you can tell
but altogether it stays in generally the
same position throughout the whole row
so that's quite good and then into this
parts where the coaster stops for a bit
which is not supposed to happen but this
is just something that occurs when
you're testing the coaster because you
can't set the exact timings but when the
coaster would be you know running for
guests this should just be a moment
where you brake a little bit before you
go into this dip which is so typical for
girl hour coasters and into a decently
strong launch then we get the top hat
here which as you can see it weights
quite a while until it banks straights
so you really kind of climb for a while
before you start turning and go to the
top normally or well I shouldn't say
normally but some other manufacturers
that are ins go slower I like to already
start twisting maybe somewhere out here
so if you look at some intamin top hats
for example the one that used to be on
canon in Liseberg you can see that
they're there differently shaped
definitely but girl hour seems to like
to have their top hats rotate very close
to the top of the elements so really you
just kind of rotate very quickly and
then just for a second at the top you
don't even get any airtime but just for
a second you're up straight and
you already rotate again to go back down
on the other side into a twisted
horseshoe row which is always a really
fun elements kind of like a very tall
drawn-out corkscrew and then a
non-inverting loop which as you can see
is pretty smooth I do have to say for
this one I sacrificed hard lining over
smoothness in planet coaster it's quite
difficult to make a smooth coaster and
it's nearly impossible to make a smooth
and hard lined inversion so for this one
I eventually decided to sacrifice the
hard line so as you can see it's a very
straight elements but altogether I think
it looks a bit better than having a
perfectly hard lined element that's not
smooth and I wasn't able to get both
done at the same time like I was for the
barrel roll at the start of the layouts
nonetheless I'm pretty happy with the
smoothing with the overall shape of this
elements and then into the stengel die
here little bit over bengts as they
should be quite snappy on those
transitions and into an Immelmann which
is pretty much a very standard a moment
and also a twisted airtime Hill here
which doesn't have too much airtime but
I think it's a nice element to
transition into the brake runs and after
that we start the second half of this
layout so as you can see it's definitely
very much inspired by takabisha which
follows the same program you know having
a barrel roll after the station into
launch and then at the second part of
the layouts which starts with the
vertical lift Hill and Beyond vertical
drop I guess the only difference really
here is that I'm using all kinds of
different elements in a different order
in an overall different layout setup
although there are some elements which
are returning from psycho-bitch and
that's something that I'll come back to
in a second for now our train has
finally reached the top there and going
down into what I can only call an
inclined dive loop there's a very rare
elements of the ink light loop which is
kind of like a loop put on its side and
this is similar to that but it's a dive
loop so yeah I'm really just following
the curvature of the elements with this
banking here so there should hopefully
be as few laterals as possible it was
just kind of feel like a vertical loop
except you're kind of on your side and
from that we move into an ejector
airtime Hill there's definitely a lot
more airtime on the the second half of
the right here especially this Hill here
provides some really sustained and very
even airtime throughout the whole Hill
and after that we move into sort of a
zero-g roll it also does a bit of a
curve but really I only had to do that
to get to the right position for the
banana roll there but yeah I guess I
could call that a zero-g roll that's
mostly what I'm going for and then after
that we finally move into the banana
roll which I have to say I think this
thing is a bit too tight as you can see
the cars kind of struggle to get through
it
which is partly also because of the
articulations of the cars they aren't
exactly right in the game but whatever
but I did make this a little bit too
tight that said this is the first ever
barrel roll that I've tried that kind of
works so I don't want to destroy this
thing this is the best barrel roll that
I've made so far so I'm pretty happy
with it into a very small bunnyhop for a
little bit more airtime and here's a not
entirely sure I should call this it's
kind of like a big barrel roll or very
drawn-out corkscrew basically the reason
for the the kind of strange shaping of
this roll is to get to this part over
the station because I wanted to have
some kind of station flyby that'll be
interesting for Rudy and open at Sur to
work with but altogether I think this
element works out quite well and it's
quite smooth as well and then it's
pretty much just finishing the core so
nothing too interesting happening here
just a few curves and then we get back
into the brake run and that's the layout
so yeah all together I'm really happy
with how this turned out it's quite as
smooth layouts and it's been a lot of
fun trying out making all of these
different elements because quite a
number of these I've never actually made
seriously so it's been a lot of fun to
work on this layouts and in the next
episode
I've heard that operator is making
episode 2 to
the building process of the the crane
and the general harbour area over here
which looks absolutely amazing the level
of detail that he went into is really
astounding even all of these little
nails and stuff like that which are
apparently billboard holders if I
remember correctly yes it's difficult to
even select them but yeah it's a screen
mount wall as you can see there's lots
of really interesting details in this
belt there so that's something you could
see on open a tourist channel for now
I'd like to thank you guys for watching
this episode and I hope to see you guys
in the next episode of this project
which will probably be on Oprah tourist
channel bye guys